uh so I expected most of the speakers
and I gotta say that lineup is pretty
legit you should definitely let me know
when uh
when when Scots and uh yeah when Scott's
in town from git coin because I haven't
seen him in a bit I'm gonna be fun to
catch up
um you have a great lineup ahead of you
uh I know many of those people and I at
least know of the rest of them
um all of them will be able to go into a
vertical very effectively I figured as a
starting point this would probably be
better to be more of a horizontal
um I'm going to be covering a lot of
weird random stuff I think I might have
two slides on things that I am
personally working on but everything in
here is something that I think very
deeply about and that's a lot of where
the space is going as [ __ ] said that I
do
uh I lead the team that used to be
protocolabs research we now bundled in a
bunch of things that act like the
research but isn't in fact research
um these are things like how to build
better uh
better infrastructure for uh like
research in that uh
it's hard to know when you've succeeded
it's hard to know how valuable it's
going to be up front it's hard to know
how much you should pay for these things
um these are problems that show up
outside of just research and they show
up in a lot of web 3 in a lot of places
and so I've taken on the task of within
protocol Labs trying to solve this for
as much of the ecosystem as I can so
with that I'm talking mostly about an
introduction to web3 generally and why
in my opinion it matters you'll see a
lot of like what is web3 and this is a
little bit less of that a little more
emphasis on the subtitle there just a
quick survey to get a sense and I'm
pretty sure this will be valuable the
other the teaching team as well I'm
curious how many of you consider
yourselves casual investors in crypto
seem to be about 20 percent
um how many of you are interested in
building something see yourself as
potentially like a CTO of some sort uh
or early engineer that might be about 50
um how many would you consider
yourselves more of the Builder on the
like operations side where you you see
yourself as more of a CEO rather than a
CTO or a chief science officer
maybe about 20
um how many of you would consider
yourselves casual observers who just
kind of want to know what's going on
here
all right that might be about 50 or 60
and then uh
how many of you are just Skeptics and
want to be able to [ __ ] on everything
and anything I say ask hard questions I
look forward to challenges from everyone
who raised hands
um please I will I have about 30 slides
and probably more more than one minute
of slide and uh
I will probably talk to them pretty
quickly so I look forward to getting
Challen hard questions challenges Etc
either here or afterward
um at the pizza hangout I will also add
a disclaimer
um
there's a lot of opinions in this the
opinions are mine they're not protocol
Labs I will probably connect more things
and identify a bunch of things more than
I will explain any individual things but
I also plan to do a lot of referencing
so you can dig into those things more at
your leisure and I will also have a QR
code that will link these slides to you
at the end of the slideshow so every
single link don't bother writing it down
don't worry about it I'll leave that
slide up as I take questions and you can
come take a picture of it afterward if
you want that should be very easy to get
a hold of me or the slides
uh last up I will highlight these two uh
this question and this topic from the
course description
hopefully this will be interesting to
you these are probably the two areas
that I will focus on the most uh lastly
I would say that my personal goal for
this particular remainder of the hour is
to convince you that there are very
reasonable and like fairly knowledgeable
people in the web 3 space the do web
space who have like fairly robust
theories of change plans that they are
implementing to achieve potentially
incredibly ambitious goals if I can
achieve if I can accomplish that I would
consider this a victory even if I can
only convince a few of you of that
I can't really start off with what is
web3 without defining web 1 and web 2
for those of you who aren't in computer
science or haven't taken networking or
electrical engineering course related to
this the internet itself is
generally the wires and the like very
basic communication for how the
computers connect to each other and on
top of that humans built the web web 1.0
is
a static internet where you can take you
can take data from one machine and view
it on another very simple these are
internet protocols that you uh or these
are internet applications that you may
or may not call applications may or may
not have actually dealt with at your age
um
because these are kind of spelunking
into the history of the internet that
said it was uh eventually replaced with
a lot of these applications where you
were interacting not with the data
directly but you were dealing with some
application that facilitated the
interaction with the data itself
uh this is much more interactive uh you
can picture these kinds of things where
the server is running some program takes
input from you before giving you output
as opposed to a very static HTML page
where it's the same content
different people emphasize different
parts of I would like to emphasize that
this is a
a verifiable web a
self-sovereign web some might say it's
an internet where you aren't limited to
Central providers who hold the data who
can who run the applications who get to
decide when the application changes I'm
sure each of you could imagine what it
would be like to have something like a
Facebook or Instagram or Twitter where
instead of only having one news feed
algorithm you've got to choose your own
that's the kind of thing that you should
expect from a potential web 3 future
um
as I
I
really enjoyed this particular blog post
titled the myth of the infrastructure
phase you may as you talk through
startupy like with with startup people
and again all of these links will be in
the slides and there will be a QR code
to the slides at the end
there's this idea that you need to
develop infrastructure before you
develop the applications that sit on top
of that infrastructure and I will
emphasize that this blog post does a
great job of dismantling that both
through logic and through examples I
will highlight the fact that the
[Music]
light bulb was invented before the
electrical outlet and plug everything
all the appliances in your home that
were electric used to screw into the
light bulb because that was the first
interface and you would like take out
the light bulb to turn on in order to
use your vacuum
um weird weird tangent but the relevance
is that you shouldn't expect to see the
most obvious things being built as
infrastructure you should expect to see
the things that will become incredibly
common showing up in a few specific
applications before those things get
universalized and so what I one thing I
like to highlight about web3 that I feel
is really underemphasized is that
there's a there are a few things where
in web 2 their applications like figma
or Google Docs or gather.town I assume
everyone's used one of those
at this point okay not even worth asking
um
the thing you can the value that those
systems bring you is your ability to
work with other people on a thing like
no one goes to Google Docs because they
really want to see a blank Google doc or
the fonts that are available within uh
like Google Drive they go there to
interact with other people
and the power of web3 is that you will
be able to interact with other people on
your own terms instead of on the terms
of a Google or a Facebook
uh
I would say this I will re-emphasize
that this is not intended to be a
standalone explainer of what web3 is I
really like these two um one from the
CEO of protocolabs who invented uh the
two main protocols that protocolab is
known for and another from our head of
ecosystem both of these are really great
explainers going to far more depth of
like roughly the previous two and the
next two slides then I will go
when it comes to pros and cons of web 2
I will highlight that there's
a fair bit of misdirection in terms of
what you experience what you are limited
to what you can choose and what you can
opt into or opt out of it's very easy in
the current Zeitgeist to look at this
and make jokes about it and the things
that I think we should be paying
attention to are things more like this
uh where it was made clear that recently
that police law enforcement could access
information from ring which is owned by
Amazon and
uh they didn't need the owner the
permission of the owner of the camera in
order to access that and the you if you
look at the interface it was made public
and it is easily capable of being abused
um
I will also highlight that's another
example it's easy to make fun of
barbecue sauce on a bookshelf but the
thing that is more important to realize
is that there are many many people for
whom Facebook is the internet
and this should be somewhat terrifying
to technologists in the room anyone who
plans to build or like anyone who
understands or tries to understand the
value that a global connectivity
communication Network provides us should
be concerned that
uh this is not just what's happening in
developing countries but it's something
that could happen when you hear pressure
toward uh some of these companies moving
into the metaverse as a space uh I
imagine all of you might recognize that
Facebook is not the internet but would
you necessarily recognize that a meta
platform zinc project or probe uh
product is not the metaverse when that
arrives
anyway I don't want this to seem
personal I don't want to Target any
particular company the important another
very important thing that I would
highlight from this is that uh
this is not a symptom of CEOs in Tech I
would claim I think that this is a
systemic incentive problem that is
growing out of the fact that when we
have centralized services that web2
provides what you end up with is a
revenue model based on attention based
on Advertising Revenue based on how
addictive can people make things and how
much can they can they monetize the data
that they are extracting from users to
whom they're giving free or cheap or at
least generally beneficial services so
uh that kind of leads us toward
what would a different incentive model
look like
um I have a few like
welcome to web3 these might be the
questions that come to mind first
um the first being why is Bitcoin
important uh obviously worth noting that
Bitcoin is like web3 is far more than
just Bitcoin but to those of you who
haven't come across this
um
I would definitely recommend this
particular explainer of what it means to
own a Bitcoin and how Bitcoin actually
works I really like three blue and brown
for math explainers generally if you
have any uh math concept from linear
algebra to Fourier transforms would
definitely recommend uh one of their
videos another Stanford grad fun fact
um
one of the benefits of like
generally I Bitcoin is this currency
like system where anyone can participate
uh your incentives are included in the
protocol itself and I think it's really
important to note that when you have
cryptocurrencies or blockchain systems
you need to have everything that is in
the domain or the regime of that project
exist or be able to be reached in a
computable way so Bitcoin is secured by
the fact that there's
some amount of energy being dedicated to
inverting a like lossily inverting a
hard to invert function
um this is I'm sure you've all heard
about Bitcoin hashing and how there are
racks of gpus that are trying to Hash to
solve math puzzles is probably the
resolution that you
May or that you may have gotten at some
point in your Learning Journey
I think Bitcoin is important not for the
uh like it's a store of value it's a
robust currency but because it was
before Bitcoin very very difficult for a
program to handle money or create a bank
account and now it's a few lines of code
and this is something like I will
usually agree to some extent and
disagree at least a little bit with any
other claim of why Bitcoin is important
but this is a fundamental shift where
like currency is now computable we have
found a way to generate digital scarcity
it used to be believed that the way that
you had to have or that it used to be
believed that you couldn't have digital
money because any string of bits could
just be duplicated and you can
counterfeit trivially
and if this wasn't a question that came
up yet
um this is like welcome to the beginning
of your uh cryptocurrency Journey
um
but
the Breakthrough of Bitcoin was We have
basically one database
uh everyone has the same copy of it and
if they have multiple copies of it
there's a
uh
there's a deterministic mechanism for
identifying the one that is the
canonical source
so Bitcoin has this Ledger it's a series
of entries about who has how many tokens
and the way that you maintain that
scarcity is that you have a series of uh
you have a series of rules about what is
a valid update and those things include
the number of tokens in have to be the
number out
in order to move from one account to
another you need a cryptographic
signature to validate that the owner of
the or the controller of that first
wallet or account
is acquiescing to the transfer and that
uh
only a certain amount of new tokens are
able to be generated at each instance
this is the block reward and that goes
to the
um
the individual or entity that
propagated the database so you have a
built-in incentive for making sure the
database continues to exist
uh
that is roughly what a blockchain is
it's a very slow database that has a
bunch of weird properties those include
an audible public history
um
often a native token but not always
often a verifiable leader election often
some creative features to try and
increase the throughput to be less of a
slow or to be a database that is less
slow than it might naturally be
there are a lot of really good flow
charts that I would say are probably the
best Avenue into understanding all the
various aspects of these uh if you
Google uh should I use a blockchain
flowchart you'll easily find like six or
seven that are really good in that they
all highlight different properties in
which you might
realize that there's a very subtle
difference between why you might use a
blockchain for this particular thing or
some other
um
type of database and uh
this is obviously I think enough that
there's an XKCD around it I'll also note
that if you look at the slides
I do have speaker notes they're not
showing up to me here but they do have
additional context on some of these
things I would love to take a question
from a skeptic at this point I think I'm
doing okay on time and if someone's like
this is uh
like this is ridiculous
thank you you highlighted a bunch of
problems with two yeah and my question
is why couldn't those problems be solved
um through regulation or changing
marketing symptoms for example
absolutely can
um they the question becomes is it
easier to change it through regulation
uh where ostensibly you need to get
buy-in from a like a ruling Coalition of
citizens and representatives or is it
easier to build a better product that
people migrate to uh and
can like where it's
like those user protections are built in
or uh
could you imagine some weird hybrid
solution where you have tools that
people become familiar with innovate
with in their free time and then go and
bring those governance mechanisms into
uh
like into from like a web 3 world into
their
uh state or local or federal governments
at the end of the day things happen
because people want them to happen
either on a microscopic scale or a
macroscopic scale and governance is as
valid a tool as any other like
governance through Federal Regulation I
think is
as reasonable a path to change Global
human behavior as governance through uh
like novel product deployment people
choosing that product and the question
becomes what becomes the easier path to
pursue more faster or less risky
multiple metrics you could apply there
take one more and then
the first thing I kind of thought about
was like how Bright's kind of mission is
like to make an API that makes like
money easy to program with a few lines
of code it's like can you go moreover
like those problems you were talking
about
so I would specifically highlight that
there's a significant amount of know
your customer and anti-money laundering
regulation straight might have to go
through you also might personally not
agree with the uh like what your
country's regulations or constraints are
on what monetary flows are just or
reasonable and uh
the
well like very mechanically if you want
to be approved as someone
transacting through like a stripe or a
PayPal automatically you like it is more
than just a few lines of code there are
definitely identity hurdles in addition
to that there are potential like robust
reasons why outside of the United States
you might want to or you might want
there to exist systems that can defy or
subvert local governments
wow okay one more
do people care that they're the product
they care about ownership like they
should I think they should
I think that the only
I think that when people know they are
the product and when people identify the
difference between
uh being the product and a different
system in which they are not the product
they are much more likely to choose to
not be the product
uh
I guess going back to
like this kind of a system
if you could choose to like knowing this
if you could choose to not buy ring
um
would that sway your decision would
having a different compete like a
different option be be enough to sway
your decision
um would it you need like robustly
audited code of an open source like
survey like uh doorbell smart doorbell
alternative in order to do that it's
there's like there is a Continuum of how
much education you need to get to people
and I I truly hope and expect that we
can have a more uh well-informed
and uh
like robustly engaged population than we
do now and that that is in any democracy
really the fundamental like Baseline for
uh civilization
so the question was what do you think
we'll take for regular people to uh
identify the law the line of the
boundary and I think that that boundary
is different for different people
fundamentally
um and that's a an aspect of humanity
that's more or less unavoidable
um I'm going to be moving on and I will
look forward to the discussion after
this
um about 15 minutes oh all right then
um nfts uh you've heard of them why
can't I right click save an image uh and
like why isn't why doesn't that kill
nfts
um there is value that we have outside
of the raw utility of an object as
humans that is fundamental and the thing
that I would hope for you to like start
considering after this although that
instead of but I can right click save
these images what does it even matter to
fund these is the fact fact that there
are artists who are now funding
themselves
by generating free art that you can
enjoy
and they are able to receive patronage
wouldn't it be amazing if we'd produced
all art like this so everyone could
enjoy it and the artists could still
generate revenue and be uh
like receive the types of funding that
we would want them to have through this
kind of patronage model I would love to
see right click saving for audit for
like ebooks in the same way they see it
for for images
you might be asking why Dows are
interesting
um
I think the dowels are the minimal
overlap the computer scientists purest
abstraction of these entities all of
them roughly have a way of tracking
membership and a way of allocating
scarce resources
um this is why I think Dows are
interesting you roughly have the ability
with Bitcoin to
uh
transact internationally with a few line
of codes as a teenager in your parents
basement
um
you can do the same thing with
blockchains but with respect to like
creating International uh
like creating Securities
um you can do the same thing with Dows
except you're creating International
corporations
um with a few friends on the internet
um this was going to fundamentally
change all of how humans interact in a
web native way because so many more of
the things that were limited to a single
jurisdiction are now embedded on the
internet in a more internet native way
I would say generally
extend that particular idea of like we
have a world where there is
jurisdictions there are uh
there are companies there are
organizations in these various forms and
you should expect that we can like we
will see the analog of those arise
um I have a hot take on
the ethereum Dao hack Fork as uh
the legitimate use of force in the
political science perspective in
political science sense
um
as like in an Internet domain but I
I don't think it's worth going into that
um
hanlon's razor is described as uh or is
usually framed as never a malice that
which is adequately explained by
stupidity and I feel like there's a
better earlier quote by geta that
misunderstandings in lethargy produce
more wrong in the world than deceit and
Malice do and at least the latter are
certainly rare
going back to what I was saying about
the incentive structure of web 2
generally being one of Walled Gardens
and ownership and monetizing free
services I think that by pushing for a
Direction Where We have
organizations that sell organizations
that generate themselves support
themselves and become
more robustly independent rather than
being these high
these
more
like free service and rent extraction
type systems will lead to huge benefits
I would say there's generally a
a an incentive landscape where people
have
some driving interest in uh
what they're like what they can do what
they know they can do and uh what will
benefit them and because everyone
follows their own little individual
incentive gradient we end up with the
world ending up in sub-optimal
situations I'm reminded of the adage
that no individual raindrop feels
responsible for the flood
um
but we can
we can definitely create Global
incentives we can create organizations
that are
better structured
and I'm realizing that I'm probably
going to want to spend more time towards
the end and uh
want to focus more on concrete things
because I feel like I'm talking at a
very high level in terms of what I see
web3 generating we are building for the
internet generally in a borderless
nation-state agnostic way a medium of
exchange a storage of value a mechanism
to regulate supply for stability and
growth probably in the near future we
are building property rights into
virtual spaces if you think about nfts
as the most robust way of establishing
who owns what in a shared communal
virtual space it becomes much more
obvious what nfts could be useful for in
a VR or ar metaverse
and additionally uh
having organizations that exist solely
in the internet and
may or may not choose to be
controlled under the jurisdiction of
some number of nation states is
something that I think we will start to
see
crypto groups leaning more into more
like increasingly strongly and so we
start to see a world where we have a an
internet native and internet first set
of like internet first world with money
property and organizations and I think
this is incredibly compelling
um I would shamelessly plug a fireside
chat that I had
um
that touches on a bit of this
um we're seeing the construction of
infrastructure for this world already a
very brief like a little bit more on
protocol Labs because it would be a
little bit uh proudly frowned upon for
me not to explain what protocol ads does
what my company is trying to do with
respect to all this we're most known for
ipfs and filecoin ipfs uh
generates a peer or makes the web work
in a peer-to-peer way where rather than
computer is all connecting to a central
server they connect to each other and if
some subset are separated from the
network they can still communicate and
that should have been well
um we generated the library to
help these computers connect directly to
each other
um it is popular enough that it now runs
the Baseline of polka dot and ethereum
in addition to our blockchain filecoin
um in ipfs you can store things and
share them in a Content addressed way
that means that you store what you care
about you give it to anyone who wants it
um I like we like to liken it more to
referencing books by a ISBN rather than
by where they happen to sit in the
library
with that system you can store things
and ask for them but you can't pay
people to store them filecoin is a
blockchain that we developed that oh and
in terms of dates it's worth mentioning
that ipfs was proposed and first
developed in 2014 phylicon was also
first proposed in 2014 but it took the
development of zero knowledge succinct
arguments of knowledge um ZK snarks in
order for this to be reasonably
buildable it was
reproposed more robustly and concretely
in 2017 and launched in 2020 you can
hire people to store your data and they
will generate
uh proofs that your data is continuing
to be stored
we also have built products like
nft.storage where because of the
incentive From the Block reward for file
coin your nfts will be stored for free
on ipfs and filecoin we also built out a
team of people to develop a distributed
Randomness Beacon
um
these are all I would say examples of
web3 infrastructure many of them I guess
all of them with the exception of
entity.storage are things that are
facing toward the uh
toward developers as users rather than
individuals
and then the last bit of the talk was
going to be a little more specific
directions on what I think we should
look for when we
or when I speculatively and dramatically
extrapolate Trends beyond what is
probably reasonable
um
from what the state of the art is today
yeah and we read to disagree I would
assume that no other speaker will talk
about these things uh
Scott Moore of Bitcoin May
um and generally I think that this is I
hope that this is interesting to you
because you can keep this in the back of
your mind when you listen to other
speakers and you see them talking in the
uh I'll say this area here extrapolating
is still a little bit but you can try
and track to what types of directions
they're leading to in the many many year
time scale
um
you will see people talking about the
future of governance governance has won
a bunch of people I Define it as one a
bunch of people
combine their resources try and
determine what individuals want they
have to aggregate the priorities and
they have to deploy those resources
against some shared goals whether this
is a United States of America or whether
this is the Dow you created with two
friends these are still the types of
things you want to do or have to do
these tools are hundreds of years old
there are better proposals for these I
would particularly
highlight Moda here which is the
ministry of oh it I'm forgetting what it
stands for it's taiwan's digital
Ministry Taiwan is a an incredible
innovator in this space and I hope that
each of you may or like I hope that each
of you will try to imagine a world in
which the governments are so effective
in implementing tools for figuring out
what citizens want that there's a robust
two-sided market for citizens ship where
people both want to go to the
governments where
they are
where what they want is better
represented and where governments are
competing over the most competent
citizens to implement those policies
I would say general or
in a drawing on something that is
probably deep background or unknown to
most of you Jurgen habermas a German
philosopher covered a lot of
social theory and democracy and
capitalism
propose the direction or extrapolated
the trend that has led us to
surveillance capitalism saying that uh
we used to have as humans uh a robust
debate that would actually impact policy
and the reason that that feels less of
the case now is because it actually is
less of the case now the discussions
that you have do not impact policy as
robustly as they used to around the
founding of America for example and what
you should expect is
that as you have commercialization of
mass media or the poor representation of
people's needs due to centralization of
services then you should expect the
public to become disengaged the
criticality to cease being productive
and people to become passive consumers
of
of the news what's going on around them
um I would say generally we can
decentralize that better we can create
uh we can Empower people with better
tools and organizations I will not go
into the future of Economics I would
link to these two things and say this is
a very interesting combination that you
should potentially consider when if
you're inclined to think about economics
for fun
um I'm not going to go into that future
of work either I there is an idea of
permissionless employment you could
imagine uh
things that are
much more
much closer to the community
organization or Union side of the scale
rather than the completely free market
or Bounty side of the scale and then
there's also some aspects of science
where this is a critical decade or
century and
how we represent what people want how we
prevent people from building things that
we don't want and how we Empower
collaboration in a decentralized way is
going to be incredibly impactful
I have a lot of random things here the
top QR code is the QR code to the slides
I apologize this ended up Meandering a
little bit more than intended the
speaker notes were
it turns out going to be more helpful
than I thought they were
um
I'm happy to stick around here until I
enter the Treehouse and I'll start by
taking questions
um as a skeptic but also as a Dev part
of your talk kind of struck a nerve with
me which is that nfts have been useful
for years why are large organizations
with mouthpieces like yours still
parroting this thing about like value
despite uselessness like they haven't
been useless they've never been useless
I have to agree with that uh I apologize
for emphasize or implying or even
explicitly mentioning a uselessness I I
think that the I would claim that the
usefulness will become will grow
exponentially which may lead to an
implication that it is not as useful now
not very useful now but I would say that
they are less useful now than they could
be when you imagine more and more
property for instance existing online IP
rights for instance being robustly
represented or cap tables being robustly
represented by tokenized structures on
blockchains people agree so why not just
say they're about to be exponentially
more useful
I will thank you
angry yeah no good reasons um the fact
that this is the first time I've given
this song that's great
um oh yeah so like on the slide about
Bitcoin the authorization that um
about like with all the scalability
emerging blockchain projects how do you
compare like the future efficiency or
performance of just like blockchain
database versus like centralized
traditional database okay the question
was how do I compare uh future
performance of decentralized databases
future blockchains compared to
centralized databases I think personally
that
there are benefit there will always be
benefits to a centralized system I think
that there are
uh systems like crdts or operational
transforms that will
give more competitive well I guess
um as crdts get closer to operational
transforms in their efficiency if that
holds meaning for anyone we'll see
breakthroughs and Technologies util like
infrastructural
level utility to make decentralized
systems more performant but I would
expect centralized systems may be asking
like maybe maybe more of an asymptote
where you can achieve in Niche
situations but there are clear values to
it that decentralization brings that
where you should care about that more
than you would care about performance
yeah almost more skeptic of like nfts so
like I I just don't understand like like
I can buy it like the Mona Lisa right
and like the reason it has value is
because I have the ability to enjoy
myself like you were the only one that
owns it right but then nft is like there
is no differentiating in like how you
like actually enjoy your content itself
so how how can nfts provide that value
so I will note nfts for art is simply
one mechanism of nft
um I would say that uh there I would
even even within that scoped case I
would expect that there will be uh
digital spaces where the fact that you
can be uh verified by Twitter for
instance as the owner of that particular
nft carries a significant social signal
and only you can enjoy that because of
the way uh
because of the way Twitter is following
the protocol